he lives in Park City Utah and
scientists stay at this Airbnb of your
pants yeah I'm not in their house yeah I
know what's your dad's name Mike how
tall is he
six Bulls huge six four three hundred
pounds by 250 full hey Mike how do I
sing how is ABS how how is your stock
portfolio looking today the market came
off somewhat from its level because
Pelosi and Bernie Sanders got into the
act on this bill again I mean at least I
understand from from a text I received I
don't believe what I read because it
said it said that Bernie put a hold
ferny is one senator and doesn't have
the authority or power to put a hold on
Mikhail's probably and ask you some
questions he's a friend of mine a comic
now let me ask you this well is there
any evidence that that the kovat 19 I
know you have some signs of staying with
you guys at the house is that you true
or false
one scientist one sighs what and that's
kind of science that's what kind of sick
dietitian what kind of
[Applause]
so so it is so did they mention or is
there been Deniz talk about the virus
maybe having been engineered in a lab
and not being made than it is coming
from a man who does not a fan of trumps
everybody has to write their headline or
write their story they all have to have
something to fill the 24/7 news cycle so
I feel sorry for you so much of what
you're hearing one thing I heard would
be very very good to do is Andrew Cuomo
had a press conference and I've never
been a fan of his either but he had a
press conference this morning and I
listened to the whole hour
New York's cases what they're doing how
they're dealing with the lack of
ventilators how they're dealing with a
lack of hospital beds and their a rate
of infection is coming down a little
less three there he says that all bad
news and New York is 15 times worse than
the next state closest to it which is
really kind of interesting don't the
reason it yeah yeah no that makes sense
[Applause]
I'm gonna have to get back to the
podcast but I appreciate I appreciate
the insight no how can we fix the
economy go I'll call you guys I'll call
you guys later for more info and and
over-under do you think we open back up
in two weeks or not no all right all
right pal see you later
talk to you later I love you dad what is
that well there it is nice Mahmoud
longevity a hand and body cream yeah oh
[ __ ] who's doing this so obviously it
hasn't been engineered I thought maybe
there was some talk about that another
scientist yeah there's all sorts of
lumber mills right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]